hey
thank you so much um
i know that i'm neither german enough
nor tall enough uh to pretend to be
their workman but um
i i guess i
at least i will cover like similar
things at the beginning as there will
have covered uh probably not a little
hard to hear
oh
i have them
oh no no
this is bringing me back memories from
nba teaching
um
does it work can you guys hear me now
okay
all right so
basically
what
what are what am i going to do basically
it's going to be two lectures on what
essentially are like special cases of
mechanism design the first one will be
about information design uh and then the
second one will be about mechanism
design with immediate commitment
hopefully by the end of the second
lecture you will see why
i think that these are two special cases
of mechanism design and how there's very
deep connections between these two
but for now i will follow the
modern econ lingo of like keeping these
two things separate
but just to give you
okay
just to give you a sense of um
where where
where the world we are going to be
living in what are the common primitives
to these two problems so we're going to
have
n agents these are going to be players
there's going to be a finite set of
states of the world this is what's going
to be representing our payoff relevant
uncertainty
and
economists like to assume common priors
i should have said i'm an economist so
that like i apologize in advance my
agents will play equilibrium
and um
and and they will have common millions
there's a set of alternatives
and then the payoffs depend on the state
of the world and this alternative so
these are the common
uh
the common ingredients to both problems
and i will refer usually to this
couple of ingredients the players the
uncertainty the common prior the
alternatives and the payoffs as the base
game
so when we think about
mechanism design what we usually do is
assume that the players have some
private information and the way we
represent that private information is by
saying
the players are going to see signals
there one will see t1 player n will see
tm and there's some relation between the
signals that they see on the state of
the world and this is something that the
players know
and i don't
know and then where
the payoffs only depend on the
alternatives of uh that i labeled a0 not
on the a13
and i'm given
a mapping that says
for each realization of the state of the
world this is what i would like to
obtain and then the question is
can i design actions for the players
and a way to map their actions into the
outcomes such that when the players play
this game that i created for them i
implement this function pi
so this is the question mechanism design
can i design a game for the players such
that even though they're privately
informed i will be able to convince them
to play in a way that gives me the
outcome that i want
so let me be more even more precise
maybe i should have
the clicker is here
so think about auction design
so
you have one ad slot so basically what
you can do is allocate the ad slot to
one place one of the players and ask the
players for some payment
and
you have a constraint that you can only
allocate one out slot so you cannot give
the odds a lot to multiple players
what is the
source of the private information
basically you can think that the set of
states of the world is a product set one
for each player
and basically each player knows their
dimension of the of the states of the
world and this is indexing their value
for the ad slot so this these players
are your advertisers
and basically what i want to implement
imagine that in google i would like to
assign the slot to the advertiser that
has the highest willingness to pay
because for instance that would
potentially mean that i can get more
money from them than if i had assigned
it to someone else
so basically google now is thinking okay
how do i design a game so that when the
uh advertisers are playing they will
um i can actually get the ad to go to
the person who values it the most
what we're going to be doing in this in
the first part of the lecture which is
called information design
now the perspective is a little bit
different so we have only the agents are
in doubt reactions
and
we're given again a mapping that says
for each state of the world what action
profile i want to implement
and then the question is
can i find
an information structure so private
information for each of the agents
such that when they play the game
so when they choose their actions under
this information structure they actually
give me the outcome that i want so
instead of designing their actions i get
to design
their information
so
let's go back
to our advertisers imagine that google
did their calculations they decided the
first price auction
now they might be uncertain
about what information the players might
have or if they will gain
further information about uh
about their value so now the actions are
just the beats because that's the game
that they're playing they're playing at
first price auction theta might be the
common value for the odd slot the
payoffs are basically the ones in the
first price auction they get the value
of the ad slot minus our payment if they
win
and we're going to have uh
and basically this pie
is might be describing possible
distributions over with profiles and
function of the of the reader's private
information
so for instance why would google care
about this they might think
they might be wondering how bad can this
distribution be
for them
so basically the so
these are the questions side by side in
mechanism design we take us given
private information and we design
actions
in information design we take us and
given the actions they belong to the
players and we ask ourselves can we
design the information structure in a
way
that we implement a certain outcome so
that is sort of the design perspective
either we are designing a game given an
information structure or we are
designing an information structure given
the basic emg
but there's a flip side perspective on
this which is the one that in economics
is becoming
more relevant now which is
um
can i so instead of thinking about
design i'm going to think about
robustness
so i am google and i'm thinking
what is the worst equilibrium that the
players complain i i chose the first
price auction what is the worst
equilibrium that they can play
and basically this is the same as asking
we will see that this is the same as
asking is there an information structure
under which there's a very bad
equilibrium that they can play
now the problem usually here is that to
be able to do mechanism design i need to
be able to talk about the space of all
mechanisms
and to do information design i need to
be able to talk about all information
structures i think this audience is more
sensitive even
than economists are to the fact that
enumerating all these things can be very
hard so what this literature seeks to do
is try to provide representations of
these mechanisms and information
structures in a way that is parsimonious
and doesn't require this like exhaustive
enumeration
so basically each of the lectures will
be about
talking about how do we represent
information structures in the first
lecture and how do we represent
mechanisms in the second lecture
and by the way i
i you have to like i understand that i
will probably use certain words in a
different way than people use words so
please
ask questions like clarifying questions
no clarifying questions
just
interrupt me
all right
so let's start with information design
so remember these are the things we know
as analysts we know the set of players
we know their actions we know the payoff
relevant uncertainty we know their
payoffs and we know that the players
share a common prayer
and we want to understand what is the
set sorry but sorry
but we do not know
neither the information structure which
is what the players know about the state
of the world
and sometimes we don't even know the
extensive form that they are playing
so are they playing the prisoner's
cinema just in action simultaneously are
they playing this prisoner still am
addressing action sequentially the first
for the most part of the talk i'm just
going to focus on uncertainty about the
information structure fixing the
extensive form
i guess
what is the
okay the
there is a common player
so i'm
i'm going to do the more most flexible
thing which is we don't know
so basically the the the
sort of the
work the exercises you're going to give
me a conjecture of over what they can
play as a function of the state of the
world
and i'm going to try to find
some
uh
private information structure
that rationalizes what they're doing
you could imagine doing the same
exercise in a world where the players
already have private information and it
will look similar to
to what i'm going to do but i'm just
going to do the
the more abstract setting where i know
nothing except that they share a comma
prior
are we assuming that's where
yes so so the the the players know this
they actually know the information
structure and as an analyst i i'm the
one that doesn't know so i know this
they also know this and it's common
knowledge between them
but they know the game that they are
playing so this doesn't define a game
because a story says i haven't defined
what the players know about theta
and what they know about what other
players know about theta
and so on and so forth
um
but they they know the game that they
are playing i as an analyst don't know
it
and yes
and the objective is this particular
fixed mapping
yes so or to describe the the things
that are
that are feasible on the things that are
not so basically the idea is
how do i represent
this map the mappings that are
consistent with equilibrium under some
information structure and the ones that
are not because the ones that are not
then
i know that there's no information
structure that will incentivize the
players to play in that way same time
google and i'm worried that
after i chose my my game my first price
auction
then these players
nature
in an adversarial way will decide their
information structure and given their
information structure
they will uh
they will play an equilibrium
then
i
this exercise will allow me to say okay
there are some things that can never
happen
so no one will
be zero
there's no information structure and
there everyone beats you in the first
place or if someone likes if i know that
someone likes a gun
so things can there will be a lower
bound as to how bad can things be there
will be an upper bound as to how good
things can be so this is sort of the the
exercise
examples of what we mean by information
structure
like what are possible
yes
yes so
let's think let's think about something
very simple so i have a seller
and a buyer the seller wants to sell one
unit of the good to the buyer
and we know that the buyer's valuation
is drawn from the common prior so
this is
my theta and i get the same notation for
the prior
so you could imagine that before
observing the price adversarial nature
chooses what the buyer learns about her
valuation
so and it and basically one possible
thing that nature could do
is tell the buyer this is your value
reveal perfectly to the buyer the value
in which case the seller knows that
nature chose to reveal the buyer the
value so when this seller chooses the
price
he will
do basically monopoly pricing using the
prior
but you could think that another thing
that nature could do is tell the buyer
look i'm not telling you anything
so you're uninformed in which case the
seller knows the buyers uninformed
and then the seller will just set a
price equal to the expectation so these
are two extreme examples of of
information structures i can make the
buyer fully informed about her value i
can make the buyer
uh
not like
sorry i can give no information about
the for the buyer about the value but
the buyer understands that prior so
her information she knows that they
expected the expected value for the good
so there's uh
assumption that nature cannot lie
like
nature can give partial information
about
uh the state of the world but cannot
give incorrect information exactly so so
basically i'm so maybe that will be more
clear in the formal definition of what
an information structure is but we are
always there will be
there will be two
in essence limitations on nature one is
that the information has to be
consistent with the prior distribution
so as you were saying nature cannot lie
and the other restriction when once we
have multiple players so here we're only
disclosing information to the buyer but
if we're disclosing information to
multiple players now the multiple
players given their information have to
do something and we're going to assume
that they will play equilibrium given
that information so those are the two
conditions that will limit
the that will give us some bite into
having a characterization of what will
happen under some information structure
because otherwise
it can become very
unruly
um
the second to last bullet
is this a case where the seller knows
the buyer is fully informed but the
seller does not know the buyer's
valuation exactly right versus the last
one the seller couldn't even know the
valuation that they would still play
um
no so if the seller knew the valuation
then the seller
so
you're right that if the seller
knew the valuation the total payoff will
be the expectation of v
so you're right that this this will be
exactly exactly the same but here what
we're saying is the the seller knows the
buyer knows nothing
the cell the only thing that the seller
can do is charge the expected value
but you're right that here the payoff
for the seller will be the same
this is a very special case where here
also the buyer is getting zero
expectation
um
but yes you can you could elicit uh
you could charge a price equal to the
valuation if you knew the value
so basically the ques if you have this
case the one the question is what prices
are consistent with equilibrium
understanding information structure i
will skip this because we i think we've
talked enough about
uh adversarial equilibrium selection the
auction
um
just before moving on
in economics information slurries yes
why would if
the
buyer
does not know anything else higher than
the prior
why would they price
the expected value
isn't there there is a symmetry if i
i prefer to charge something lower
because i want to
to get
money
in more cases i guess oh we are
we're assuming here like you can charge
the expected value minus an epsilon and
the buyer will accept and then you can
make that epsilon very very small
because the buyer doesn't know anything
else
exactly
exactly
so just before moving on and i'm and
probably i'm missing lots of of names
but
in economics the this idea of the
adversarial using this tool for
adversarial equilibrium selection
um
is more common than for instance in our
computer science even though information
design is being used a lot there's like
i'm seeing more and more submissions to
see regarding uh information design
there the idea in in these papers is how
can i for instance how can a platform
release information about quality to uh
get buyers to consume or how do you
release information to your uber driver
so that they get a take out right etc
etc so is this more like
this
mechanism design perspective too
um
to this problem
so let me i'll start being more formal
so that i can answer especially
slaughter's questions let's think about
the single agent example
when they're so that there is no
question about the extensive form i have
one player they move once
they are always the first and the last
to move
so
and i will be using the following
example just to fix ideas
the the player can choose to contribute
to
or or not contribute
to fund a public good and the value of
the public good can be lower high
and there is a cost to providing this
gun
and the buyer if he knew that the state
is low he doesn't want to provide this
go the the
the good and he has he does want to make
the contribution if the state is high
and basically the payoffs are if the
buyer if a player contributes
he gets the value minus the cost and
zero otherwise
and i'm i'm going to call me not the
probability of the state is high and i'm
going to assume that without information
it is not optimal
to
uh to contribute
so basically that's the question that we
have what are the joint distributions
over
values
of the public good
and profiles of country are not
contributors that are consistent with a
rationality under some information
structure
and to answer thor's question and i
think this will also address
uh shuchi's question is what is an
information structure is going to be a
signal structure
so we're going to have a set of signals
and a mapping
that assigns to each state of the world
distribution over those signals
so this is hard this is like hard coded
information so basically the idea is
nature will draw
the state and a signal
the player
observes the signal but not the state
the signal could be the state so the
player could learn the state
and the player knows both the prior and
the signal structure
and we as analysts don't know the signal
structure
and then the player decides whether to
contribute
does this make sense
so
observing basically the signal the
player will update her belief about
whether the public good is good or not
and then we'll choose an action to
maximize her payoff
and in this case this is basically
if her posterior is sufficiently high
about the state being high
then she contributes if the um posterior
is sufficiently low she doesn't
contributes there's some kind of belief
at which she's indifferent between
contributing and not contributing
this is just rationality and then when
we have many players this will be
equilibrium
so
given the signal structure then i can
ask myself what is the probability under
the signal structure
that the player takes action a when the
state is stated
and i'm just using the best response
and then
i can construct my candidate p
pi just by multiplying it by the prior
which i know as an analyst
so basically
then the question is
um
what are the joint distributions over
actions and states of the world that i
can write like this
so you can see that there's already some
structure to the pipes that are possible
and the biceps are not
any questions
yes sir can you just show us the
definition
yes no of course
so basically i'm i'm doing
um love total probability so i know
given the signal structure now i can
calculate i know the agent's payoff so i
can calculate their best response
and that gives me the probability that
under that signal structure they take a
certain action in a given state
and then when i multiply that by the
prior i have the probability of taking
an action when the state is theta okay
so the kind of given i-hat is really
like under information yes yes i i just
thought that if i wrote by till of my
heart
um
so you're trying to find is there a
signal structure exactly so i want to
find if if you give me a pie
if you give me a pie i want to say can i
find a pie hat
such that the pie that i started with is
pie tilda of my heart
there is a trust issue here
that uh you know the nature
you know reports that i had
uh the asian trust that says
yes
take that as a given or
so we will take that as a given in the
sense that
um
yes so i i will i will take that as him
for now there is a
for the single agent case there's a
whole literature in economics that's
called bayesian persuasion where you're
thinking that this by hat is being
designed by someone that is very
interested in the agent's action
and there the issue of trust is very
relevant because this person is
designing like a single structure
releasing information is trying to
convince me to take an action that might
not be the one that i wanted to take
um
and then i would be more concerned about
the issue of trust but here we're just
doing an exercise where like nature is
metaphorical
i just don't know the
what the agent knows about the state of
the world and basically can summarize
this by
by an information structure so so it's a
metaphorical nature rather than a
uh
like us a real sender
okay so this is just in math the set
that we want to so this i'm going to
call pi mu 0 because of course this set
depends on the prior the set of the
spies that can be rationalized by some
pi hat
so
yes
can you can you walk a little bit about
what's the difference between these
invasion perspectives
mathematically these are the same but i
think that the
the question is sort of different
because if i if i was here trying to get
i don't know maximum contribution
for uh
for the
i'm i'm the the person that's in charge
of information structure i don't know
it's kickstarter and they are trying to
get maximal contribution and they are
going to try to convince everyone that
comes to kickstarter that what they are
seeing is good
once you think that people are trusting
your however you release information the
stars you give or whatnot you can
imagine that now kickstarter has an
incentive to start like putting more
stars i am going to actually the second
part of the talk will be about
some sort of trust issue and mechanism
design
but for now i'm going to instead of
thinking about
there's a sender that has a side agenda
i'm just using nature as a metaphor for
the information structure
yes
so
i'm just copying the formula so that
people don't need to remember but
there's already this already tells you
some structure that
that any
pie that is consistent with an
information structure has to satisfy
the first restriction
is the prior so
i know the prior so when i take the
marginal of my pie over the actions
it has to be that
i match the prior
and that's in a sense that the restrict
one of the restrictions that uh she was
alluding to which is when i trust when
i'm tying nature's hands
nature cannot decide cannot convince me
of anything
on average i have to the the variety of
the state of the world has to be as in
the project
because um
this will when i i will
in a couple of slides i will have
a property where this translates to
the distribution of posterior beliefs
under the information structure averages
to the prior
so that's why there's some the
inverted quotes
and then
basically
the other thing
is that for every action that i take
with positive probability under pi
it has to be
that when that that action is optimal
for me
so if pi is consistent with
the actions that i take under some
information structure it has to be that
uh
this is satisfied
and this this comes like
so that no one has to
figure out me i don't know if it's
obvious or or if it's liking meals or
not so so i okay i'll i'll just go for
it
so i have a pie that's that that i know
that it comes from an information
structure so i'm just deriving necessary
conditions
so
i take my pi
because it's written as pi tilde
i can um
i can sum over a c of the world i can
sum over the signals
and here i'm missing a u so there's a u
of a theta
and then basically what i what i do is
i'll flip the way that i'm adding that
i'm adding the state and the signals
and i'm going to multiply and divide by
the total probability of observing a
signal
and then if i
put this probability
inside here
what i have is the belief under which
the action is taken
and basically
we said that when the signal is s
if the agent is taking action a then a
is the optimal action for that belief
so that means and this holds for all
these signals because that's the action
that i'm taking so it has to be that
this is better than any other action
that i could have chosen
so basically one way to think about this
is that if pi is consistent with
uh
with rationality whenever pi says that i
take action a
a should have been optimal for me
so these are just necessary conditions
when we know that the pi comes from an
information structure
and it turns out that these are both
necessary and sufficient
so if you give me any pie
that satisfies what i call the
martingale property
and satisfies this obedience condition
then i can find an information structure
under which
this is the distribution over actions
and states of the world that i will
obtain
and the information structure is the one
that i described before which is you
just sell nature just tells the agent
what to do
and
maybe here
uh church's question will become
relevant again but basically because
nature is just metaphorical this is a
nice way of representing an information
structure i just tell the agent
what to do
and the information structure will
satisfy because of this condition that
whenever i tell the agent to do a a is
what they will want to
but this is just a representation it's
not
it's one way for us
to summarize something complicated and
having signals and labels what not
here's a nice set of labels
and here's a condition
that
that pins down the signal structure
questions
yes
no no no
so basically here here what the only
thing i'm trying to show
is that if i knew
that my pie can be written as
the pie till of sempei hat
then
when
i have to have that
the the agent prefers to do a over any
other action
so basically what i did was
i wrote pi using the definition of
phytila
i changed the order of integration
because i want to write
here the condition that a is optimal
whenever the agent sees signal s which
is this indicator function
so basically what i did was i i i didn't
subtract i i multiplied and divided by
by the probability of the signal so i
could get the the the belief under which
the
the action was taken so basically the
only thing i did was
rewrite the information structure as the
probability of seeing a thing the
payoffs as the probability of seeing a
signal and maybe this condition on that
signal
and that's the and this is the payoff
under which the action is optimal
that's uh
any other questions
yes
any
so
basically why
let me just
wrap up this part by saying why do we
care about this so now we have a
characterization of our set pi
uh
it's
nice
of the set of primary nodes and it's a
set of distributions that satisfy a nice
system of linear inequalities
and now you could think there's a third
party that's interested
in whatever the the agent is going to do
and if you wanted to do something like
patient persuasion where you're much
where you're like
trying to
sorry i
i'm one slide ahead so basically you
have a third party he has some payoff
that depends on the action on the states
and
now we know that the payoffs that this
third party can get
because of the actions that the agent
take
can only be described by pies that
satisfy our conditions
so if our third party was a designer
that's in control and the agent trusts
him
then he can look at our sets and say
okay i'll look at the
thing that maximizes my payoff over that
set
but if we think that maybe nature is
choosing
what the the information structure that
the agent has
uh in an adversarial way now we can
describe the minimum for the of the
payoff of the third party in that set
and all these
problems are linear programs
so there's that so the problem now has a
nice structure you don't have to be
enumerating signals or anything i'm just
looking at
at the program that is linear in in pi
with constraints
now given that people asked about
bayesian oh sorry one one last thing is
if we go back to our example
then now we can characterize our set
using the payoff function for so
basically using the martingale property
we know that we only need to
characterize the probability that the
agent contributes from the status high
and when the state is low
and then we can use the agent's payoffs
basically
to get the obedience constrained and
this gives you
a condition on how frequently the agent
has to contribute on the high state to
be willing to contribute on the on the
low state
and one of the reasons to put up oh
the i had something here that it's not
showing up so one of the reasons to to
show these figures you can see that
there's a nice duality between so once i
have the payoffs i can give you the set
of feasible distributions but you could
imagine yourself asking this
a different question which is
if i give you this and i told you
whatever the agent's payoffs are
this is what
this is a set of feasible distributions
consistent with rationality then you
could imagine
uh getting the train to estimate the
agent's fails
and vasily skirjanis has a paper with
the timber andrew asiany where they are
actually doing this for first price
options
so you can use this
tool to sort of flip the question if you
know pi can can i learn you and vice
versa
now people were asking about bayesian
persuasion
so bayesian persuasion is of it's the
same as this the problem that i have
described but it is using different
signals
so what did we do
we got the signal from nature we got the
agent's beliefs we
determine the agent's action
and
as long as the belief is above and below
this threshold then i know exactly
beyond the belief what's the action that
the agent took
the problem is that the belief doesn't
necessarily pin the action
of the agent at indifference
so in general that's why the
having signals equals to actions is
nicer because you don't need to worry
about how the agent is breaking ties
but if you knew how the agent is
breaking ties
then you have a mapping from the agent's
beliefs
to the agent's actions
so you can basically
think of
an obedient signal structure so you can
think of implementing the same
distribution over states
of the world and actions either by
telling the agent what to do
or telling the agent what belief he
should have
where the information structure
will be taken in a literal way in the
sense that if the information structure
tells you new
when you do this rule
you update to me
so this is what people
this is the object that people work with
invasion persuasion because they have a
selection of the
best responsible response which is you
break ties in favor of whoever is
designing the information structure
so basically what this says is that when
you have a single agent you can either
recommend the agent what action to take
or tell the agent the belief he should
have both signals will work
and each approach has its downsides
the belief approach requires knowing how
the agent breaks size
but the action approach is complicated
if the action space is complicated so
maybe you have a continuum of actions
but you have two states
it's better to talk about beliefs and
actions
now these literal signal structures are
blackwell experiments
so i'm basically i can think about the
blackwell experiment as inducing a
distribution over posteriors and this is
where
ali's question uh becomes relevant which
is that if i have a literal
a literal information structure that
gives an institution where posters the
distribution or posters is also a nice
object to work with you might wonder
which are the
distribution of our posters that i might
get and it will be those that satisfy
that are consistent with the prior so
the
if i
average out my posterior beliefs they
average out to the prior
so this is yet another way of describing
these
signal structures once you allow me to
use beliefs as signals rather than
actions
so if you are familiar with bayesian
persuasion you do this in your sleep
but
when you go to multiple agents it will
be easier to have the action
characterization rather than the
belief characterisation
so in the actions
sorry
it's this
so in the
the condition that the prior puts limits
as to how i can disclose information
it's this one
and when i write it in the space of
beliefs what i will get is that
so you could think of a
as the probability of the belief that
induces a
and that will give you that you have to
average to the prior
yes
simple simplex
yes
yes i'm trying to understand
why that is
because basically if i
if
my
um
my signal structure now takes states
into distributions of our posteriors
so
i draw the state of the world and then i
sometimes tell you you should believe
that
theta h has probability half and
sometimes theta h has to have
probability two thirds
and hopefully your priorities between a
half and thirds because otherwise you
will know that
uh my information it's not consistent
with
uh with the pride
but you're in in the other in the other
information structures you just draw an
action
here you draw a belief
any other questions
okay so
just um
just to give i i
i want to show you where the
so we've been assuming that the agent
sees the signal and then takes an action
that's optimal for them
i want to show you how that translates
with many agents
uh so that i can so i show you the
hidden assumption of equilibrium in in
all of this
um
so we so basically now we're back to
many players we're going to start by
assuming that the players take their
actions simultaneously
so
an information structure will be the
same
as before but now i need signals for
each of the players
because i might want to tell player or
nature and i want to tell player 1
something that it doesn't tell player 2.
um so basically everything will be the
same as before the players know t1 so so
the players know the information
structure they observe their realization
of ti they don't observe what the others
see
or the state of the world but they but
they know
it's common knowledge that this is
information structure under which
they're playing the game
and
the thing is that
here we could have been done with the
one in the one player case but in the
end player case if i want to know what
player i will do now
well player i need to think about what
the others will do
so we need to close the model by saying
how the players form conjectures about
what the others will do as a conditional
on the signals and the assumption in
this literature is that players are
going to play a base nash equilibrium
so basically what the exercise is
trying so
this is just the definition of bne
um
you so if you know base match
equilibrium
you can for you don't need to read this
but basically what we're going to say is
that
each player will choose a strategy and a
strategy is a fun as a function of their
signal what they're going to do
and basically they're going to be best
responding to the others
strategies so they're going they know
the prior
they know the probability that their
opponents are of different types given
their type and each state of the world
they have a conjecture correct about
what the others are doing and it better
be the case that then they don't want to
deviate from the original plan
so
the single agent is a nicer thing but
then basically if you give me an
equilibrium i can do the same thing
again so before here i have a pie hat
now i have psi but again i can ask
myself what is the probability that the
agents take certain actions given the
state of the world and i can get my
uh
my joint distribution over actions and
states of the world the same way i did
before
yes so uh so you're thinking of natural
equilibrium you're saying that's the
sort of generalization of obedience
so well it will
yes
it is um so this is the
the generalization of the optimization
condition so we said that the agent
before sees the signal s
and takes an action that is optimal for
the updated belief
here
i'm going to say the agency signal ti
but in order for him to know what's
optimal to do he needs to think about
what the others are going to do and i'm
going to close that with equilibrium
meant
um
you're once right ahead because there is
a definition of obedience in this
setting
which is
my i'm going to say that the pie
satisfies obedience if when i tell the
agent to do ai
and he asks himself well what are the
others doing
according to this they are doing a minus
psi
and the state of the world is theta when
the agent calculates all these
contingencies on average he refers to a
i over a i prime
and it turns out that um
so so the very moment brooks and morris
they define this
they define the pies that satisfy this
obedience condition
and the martingale property of the prior
as base correlated equilibrium
so this is
very similar
to what we did for the single agent case
except that now i need to embed some way
in which the players form beliefs of
what the others are going to
but then the
and if you're familiar with correlated
equilibrium in non-cooperative in theory
it this is this definition
but when there's only one state of the
world so the martial properties mute
and basically the theorem
in
uh derek and stephen's paper is
basically a characterization of
so b if you
a distribution over
actions and states of the world
can occur in equilibrium under some
information structure if and only if it
is a vc
and again the information structure that
works is you tell each player privately
what they
should and you don't tell them anything
else about
what the others are doing
that's not saying anything about the
realism of this information structure is
again a representation of how um
of what the players are doing
and again as in the single agent case
this has if you're maximizing over this
set you're maximizing over a set that's
defined by a set of linear inequalities
so it's a nice set to work with
do you need to know the type
of oil do you need to know the types of
all ages
know
so so to to him to implement
so so
actually who needs to know the designer
or the
device so the correlating device only
needs to know the state of the world
so the correlating device condition
gives recommendations
based on the state of the world
and again i guess this is also related
to sri's question about trust
but but but basically yes so our base
quality equilibrium the coordinating
device can give different
recommendations as a function of of the
state of the world
and if i didn't
allow for this conditioning this will
also be
a form of uh
like blind correlated equilibrium but it
wouldn't capture
all the things that players could do
with private information
yes
and there i guess the answer is the
correlating device needs to
needs to know the signals yes
yes that's a good point so just uh
what kits were saying is that
we could and this is i think that
relates to flores question if we started
with a
a setting where i as an analyst know
that the players already have like some
signal structure and i'm worried that
they might learn more
but they already have some information
then i will be carrying here also the
signals that they already have so the
this fictitious nature is going to be
coordinating the agents both on the
basis of the state of the world but also
their signals
and there's refinements of this notion
that for instance require nature to
incentive to elicit this information
from the players
so um
so because
i assume that in some cases basically
the
the
one of the information designs that
makes this feasible what recommends you
said it recommends actions to the
players
if the nash equilibrium is randomized
does the mechanism
recommend a distribution of her actions
or does it randomly recommend an action
it randomly recommends an action
um
you mean
so you would be asking me two things um
the one is
are there incentives their incentives
will hold
but
uh
one thing that always happens because is
that it could be that once i ask you to
do one action
you're actually different between two
actions
and i'm assuming that you will do the
one that i told you to do
or
i'm assuming nature as soon as you will
do what nature told you to do
so there is this potential but it's way
nicer
to work with
recommendations
on actions
rather than the randomized actions
because i will give the the program and
the language of the signals will become
much more complicated
any other questions
of course
what is
so you could think so
going back to example that that that i
had before you could think that
your google you decided you're running a
first price auction
and you know the distribution from which
the values are drawn but you don't want
to make more assumptions about
what's the nature of how this
information is distributed amongst the
players
but you know that whatever the nature of
that information is they're going to
play equilibrium
so now you have this the
characterization of this set
and now you can
see how bad or good your revenue is
under first price auction by calculating
your payoffs over this set
so maybe you're very optimistic and you
think that the players you're a full
designer so you can control the
equilibrium within the first price
auction you're going to choose the one
that maximizes your revenue
but if you're thinking that for every
game for the first price auction nature
is actually trying to mean maximum
you're you're going to go to the worst
uh base correlates equilibria to
evaluate your payoffs from the first
price auction
and in fact dirk and stephen and ben
brooks have a couple of papers trying to
think about the robustness of different
auctions using this methodology
so
is there a bit descriptive rather
like trying to
analyze
the outcome of
analysis rather than
select
exactly so he this is a nice represent
so
people have been doing mechanism design
on the
presc in the
i'm i have full control of the rules of
the game for for a long while and i
think that
this audience is very sensitive as to
how many times you're not in control
this is a tool that allows you to think
about
worst case scenario
in um
still at least in the language that
economists are
more comfortable with which is like what
are the restrictions that are imposed by
a compriser and equilibrium but now
you're not in control of information so
there are some things that you're not
willing to make assumptions on
yes so this will be
this because you know the payoffs
the we have these conditions and then
you have the marginal property and
basically if you
if you all have expected utility
basically you're going to be calculating
your payoffs multiplying by this so you
everything will be linear in pi
any other questions
so
i have
[Music]
four minutes which is terrible to do one
more thing but then i i have a very
simple example that
i wanted to show that i want to show you
because if you're thinking about
adversarial nature you might sometimes
think that nature has even more power
which is to contact the player
sequentially
and this is something that
i work with on with jeff ili so
basically the question is the
ingredients are the same as before
players are going to take one action
but you don't know neither how nature is
closing information
nor how the a nature is contacting the
players
so the players are not required to take
action simultaneously and in particular
this means that maybe nature can give
recommendations as a function of what
people have done in the past
so let me show you a very simple example
with no states of the world
and
and this is not even our example we
found it in a
later on we were very happy with this
example and then later on we found it in
a paper by nishihara from 1997. um
so basically this is the prisoner's
dilemma
so we have the pair from deviating
is better than the payoff from both
cooperating and of course if they both
deviate they ruin society
and i want to show you that if the
payoff from
being gone is better than
uh the average between deviating uh
unilaterally and deviating jointly then
i can find an extensive form where both
play cooperate with probability one
even though they are moving once
so how am i going to do this i'm going
to flip a coin and decide who moves
first
the players don't know
who moves first
i'm going to contact the first mover who
doesn't know that he's the first mover
i'm going to tell them to play cooperate
and
if they cooperate i'm going to tell the
second player to play cooperate
and if
the first player defects i'm going to
tell the second player to defect
and my claim is that under that
condition then they both cooperate with
probability one
so let's reason through this
so
if you're one of the players and you
hear the recommendation to defect
of course you're going to defect you
know that you're the second mover and
the other guy played defect it's a
dominant strategy to play the effect
and
if you're
being told to cooperate well if you
follow the recommendation
because you think that the other one
will follow the recommendation you get
the bill from cooperating
and now you're thinking what happens if
i detect
well it could be that i'm the last
person to move and i got the
recommendation to cooperate in which
case the other guy cooperated and
therefore i get the good payoff from
deviating
or it could be that i'm the first one to
move
in which case
nature will
go and tell the other person to defect
and they will defect because we we just
verified that
so this is the condition that i have
there
now this says that basically i'm going
to cooperate
and basically in the paper we show that
the same way that
disobedient recommendation struct
information structures implement the set
of all vc
then
for me uh extensive forms like this with
obedient recommendations are the ones
that
implement represent equilibria across a
family of extensive forms
but if you're really interested you can
see that
this has more power there's no
information
you you just approach the player
sequentially so if you're thinking about
like adversarial equilibrium selection
this nature is more adversarial than the
one in dc because it has more tools to
to go against the design
okay
i'll
shut up now
um unless there's questions but
i'll i'll finish
uh i don't remember it
on from the top of my head but we can we
can calculate it because we also get a
linear program
um
you know so yes and if this doesn't hold
you can you cannot get them to cooperate
because we have some restrictions on the
extensive form so that the players still
have to choose their actions
in a competitive way
so we don't let them
we don't allow them to write contracts
in extensive form so i cannot say if you
cooperate i automatically cooperate and
if you do a feed effect automatically
effect we cannot write those contracts
it's still like non-cooperative play in
extensive form
yes we're going to use
perfect basin equilibrium
and actually a big part of the
paper and that's why i'm only showing
this example and i think the the other
what was better for for presentation is
that a lot of the papers like how does
this this set changes as you make
as you go from base nash equilibrium all
the way to stronger and stronger
refinements of
sequential rationality
thank you